but I get now to introduce one of the
most powerful women in the world I mean
if we are to escape from the mess that
we're in right now she is going to play
a major part in helping us do that she's
the head of the International Monetary
Fund I delight to welcome here
Krista Lina Georg Eva Krista you know
why be with your Greece thank you thank
you for having me
so you just took on this role late last
year and within four months boom Kove it
arrives that is one heck of an
introduction to a new job how are you
doing well I find strength in action and
at the front we have been from day one
on this crisis leaning forward with
everything we have to provide lifelines
to countries and that means to people
and businesses already 9:00 in we have
received over 90 requests and we have
offered to 56 countries critical
financial packages I mean you've
described this pandemic as a crisis like
no other in what way a crisis like no
other
hmm truly like no other first never
before we will inflict on the economy
consciously so much pain to fight a
virus and save lives we are asking
businesses not to produce and consumers
not to go out and consume at the front
we label this the great lockdown second
never before there would be such a wrap
it change of fortunes practically for
for everybody around the world in
January I was in Davos talking about
anemic growth growth of 3% in April
during our spring meetings it was
already minus 3% in January we predicted
a hundred and sixty countries to have
positive income per capita growth now it
is a hundred and seventy countries with
negative income per capita growth now
this we call the great reversal very
painful and an entry uncertainty we we
always live with uncertainty a crease
but this time it is the uncertainty of a
novel coronavirus that policymakers have
to integrate we had the fund combine
epidemiological projections with our
traditional macroeconomic modelling to
see true that uncertainty I must add to
this I very much hope that when we go on
the other side in the recovery we can
use a new term and call it the great
transformation make the world a better
place
well I'll be excited to come on to that
in a bit but in this moment of
responding to the crisis the main tool
that seems to have been executed at
least by the the rich countries has been
this this massive economic stimulus to
the tune of trillions of dollars is that
a wise response it is necessity and you
don't hear the fund often telling
countries please spend spent as much as
you can and that is what we do now we do
add to that and keep the receipts don't
lose accountability to the citizens to
the taxpayers
the reason financial injection is
necessary this fiscal measures of almost
nine trillion dollars are necessary is
because when the economy is standing
still unless there is help unless there
is monetary policy stimulus firms are
going to go massively bankrupt people
would be unemployed the economy would be
scarred when we go to the other side
this scarring is going to make the
recovery much more difficult so that is
a wise thing to do and it helps the fact
that central banks in major economies
have been acting in a synchronized
manner and that fiscal stimulus came
really really fast this is how we see
people being able to go through this
very very tough time but how far can it
go because it's been described in a
census as printing money governments are
issuing more and more bonds that have to
be paid back at some point there's this
term in economics you know of the Minsky
moment where things can go very well for
a while as as everyone believes that you
know the the train can keep running the
cycle can keep turning you know that
governments have all this money at at
some point though doesn't that break
down do you worry that we may be nearing
a Minsky moment where like Michael and
Mary Poppins grad just happens and
starts a run on the bank is is that is
there is there stress in the
international financial system now that
concerns you that makes you feel that we
may be running out of headroom
of course this cannot go on forever I
for one have trust in our scientists I
think we will see
breakthroughs and we will see also
people in businesses getting accustomed
to social distancing to micro measures
that protect from spreading the disease
we have seen very massive in
objection in health systems so hospitals
can actually treat people that are
coming for help
obviously if it is to go for a very long
time we would be worried for now what we
are projecting is that there would be a
gradual reopening we see it already
happening in a number of countries and
we project for next year 2021 partial
recovery not a full recovery
unfortunately but coming to a better
place now what helps us is something
that I don't particularly love but I see
it as a positive feature very low
interest rates in some cases negative
that allows this injection of fiscal
measures and liquidity to be sustained
over a number of years and for now we do
not see on the horizon any return to
increase in interest rates so low for
longer and that is in that environment a
helpful feature I mean the financial
crisis of 2008 kind of came perilously
close to breaking the entire financial
system arguably it did that by most
people's calculation this is a far worse
impact to the economy overall did the
world learn something from 2008 that has
helped us so far be resilient this time
what the world learned is that the
financial system has to be tested and
then strengthened to withstand shocks
and that is helping us tremendously
today the banking system is resilient
and even in the non banking financial
institutions there is more attention
paid to how far can you go we
about running into into trouble I would
say if you look around the world the
most important lesson then was built
resilience to shocks those who have done
it cop now better and those who have not
done it are in a much tougher spot and
actually for the fund what we are
praying is that we will come out of this
crisis with this lesson about resilience
being spread beyond the banking system
so we actually had this crisis
management mindset for a world that is
inevitably going to be more shock prone
because of climate and also because of
the sheer density about economic and
social life on our planet in your role
you're paying a special attention to the
situation in developing countries and it
does seem that they're facing at a
really terrible situation right now
many of them have significant debt
denominated in dollars in the current
crisis their currencies are depreciating
against the dollar making it nigh
impossible for them to execute the kind
of injection stimulus injections that
the rich countries are doing and seems
to be the only way out so that seems
like a really dangerous cycle is there
any way to break that cycle well let me
first separate countries that have built
strong fundamentals and now in this
crisis as we are receiving incoming data
they are not very many but there are
still some positive surprises and they
come from countries that have built
stronger buffers stronger fundamentals
have been more disciplined during good
times but indeed we do see a quite a
number of emerging markets developing
countries faced with multiple pressures
they have the heat from the
Ronna virus may many of them with weak
health systems then they have the high
level of indebtedness from before the
crisis which creates much more difficult
environment for them then many of them
are commodity exporters commodity prices
oil price went down very dramatically
that hits them again many rely on
remittances remittances shrank some 20
to 30 percent and then you have a number
of countries that are highly dependent
on tourism tourism is the hardest hit
sector of one of the hardest hits so
very tough for these countries but this
is why institutions like mine have been
wisely created the IMF the World Bank
the Regional Development Bank's we work
very closely together in this crisis the
IMF fortunately that was one of the
lessons from the 2008 2009 crisis make
sure that in the center of the financial
safety net is an IMF with financial
strength we have four times more money
to lend today than we had them from 250
billion to 1 trillion dollars and of
course we are deploying these funds
exactly for the countries that need us
the most
and we did one more thing with the David
Malpass the president of the World Bank
we called for a debt moratorium for the
poorest countries to their official
bilateral creditors and your people tend
to say oh we don't work together it's
not good enough but here is an area
where we made this call in late March
and in mid-april the g20 agreed on this
moratorium amazing we had the Paris Club
China the Gulf countries all agreeing
that we should not suffer
yet the poorest countries by asking them
to pay their debt where their economies
are standing still is it possible that
some developing countries are overdoing
the lockdown policy I mean if large
numbers of your citizens are already
struggling to stay alive isn't it almost
like a death sentence to order them not
to leave their homes well Chris one of
the most heartbreaking conversations I
would have is with leaders of countries
where they have to stare in the face a
choice of people dying from the virus or
dying from hunger and it is a very
dramatic very dramatic situation for
them where you have a very large part of
your economy being informal where people
live hand-to-mouth every day the
lockdowns we have in advanced economies
are not quite applicable but even their
countries are doing really well in
social distancing to extent it is
possible many of the countries in Africa
were very early to step up preventive
measures why they learned from the Ebola
they learned from prior crisis that
hygiene taking any measure you can
really really helps so again I cannot
stress enough how important is
solidarity with these countries how
important is for my institution to be
there for them in a timely in a timely
manner and we do it weigh me right there
thank you this is a wonderful
conversation and we're starting to see
some questions come in from the
community there's gonna turn over here
so I can read the first one we have ism
from bill alkis and it's a follow up to
something you were mentioning earlier
related to the stimulus on Kristalina
what are the prospects for inflation
from such large simulus at this point we
are not worried about inflation in
advanced economies and majority
emerging market economies we do worry
about inflation in countries that have
weak fundamentals no access to foreign
exchange easily where the only way to
address the crisis is our help or their
central bank's printing more money and
sometimes it's a combination of those
two why I don't worry about inflation in
advanced economies because countries
that have their hard currency are
putting liquidity in place but at the
same time they are not seeing a big
expansion of demand and prices being
pushed up so for this country's at least
for observable future we don't see a way
of going like after the Second World War
in inflation jumping up the consumers
are not consuming so aggressively demand
is not that strong and these are
societies where there is a lot of
maturity in how they exercise their
policy options but if you are a poor
country that out of desperation with no
access to markets no access to hard
currency ought to somehow put money
supply enough then inflation is going to
be there a very extreme cases a Zimbabwe
and I do worried there may be other
countries so this is why we are so
determined to engage with these
countries early and also look at some of
the high bed countries would it be
necessary on a country-by-country basis
to restructure debt to prevent that
moving gina in a desperate direction
thank you me and we have one more
question that I wanted to share from our
our community this is from Keith
Yamashita and it's about sort of how we
all can be involved in some of this
change you're tasked with macroeconomic
and funding efforts what should we do as
citizens to help renewal and recovery
but it is incredibly important for all
of us citizens and aside to being the
head of the IMF I am also a global
citizen that we are to bring that notion
of solidarity in a moment of crisis I
loved the way this segment was musically
backed and it was lean on me it is very
important that we do create that sense
we are in this together we would get
through it together and please speak up
on that I was for many years crisis
commissioner and one thing I learned is
that majority of people are positive
good people you can lean on them and
there is a minority that is hateful and
fearful and also very loud so good
people speak up spread that sense of we
are in this together
we'll get through it together thank you
now I'll come back later with other
questions
Katsura I'd love to expand on that and
just ask you a bit more about about
leadership actually you know when people
think of the nations that have performed
best they often refer to I'm gonna say
best best in response to the current
pandemic they often refer to Germany New
Zealand
South Korea Taiwan Denmark and Norway
when they think of those that have
performed worse helfen
think of Spain Italy the UK Belgium
Sweden Iran Brazil Russia and the United
States all of that second group are run
by men all but one of the first group
are run by women is that a coincidence
well now speaking a bit subjectively as
a woman I do believe that women are
great to lead in a crisis they are more
likely to show empathy to care about the
most vulnerable people and to be able to
speak about that they are decisive I can
say that for myself day we take energy
from action and we don't tend to kind of
morning complain too much so there is
perhaps something to be said about the
value of gender equality for the future
bring more women for this world of more
crisis ahead of us I mean let's
obviously how to make generalizations
about gender of any kind but I mean I'm
is there also almost something about the
embracing of nuance that women might be
better at that than men men often it's
like let's win let's let's conquer and
in a situation like this where it's all
probabilities it's like it's there are
so many complex dials to turn on this
this dangerous pandemic machine that
we're trying to wrestle that better let
me say something Chris we need everybody
and we need this mixture of experience
knowledge and predisposition men and
women coming together
I find it that it is great to have
different perspectives when we make
decisions then the chances of making a
good decision are higher so we need each
other but we also need to recognize his
that yes there are certain things I have
seen it time and again
women are more willing to find a pathway
to compromise they're more willing to be
corrected if they're wrong say oh okay
that's a good point let me integrate it
in the way I think about it and so when
you are in uncertainty that is a huge
advantage in decision-making so perhaps
talk a bit more about your own
leadership in this moment I mentioned
you've only recently come to this job
but before that you were a European
Commissioner you dealt with humanitarian
crises in more than one part of the
world and in your own country Bulgaria
you witnessed the wholesale
transformation of the country both
politically and economically what
lessons can you bring from from your
past experience to this moment well
there are there many things I learned I
was very fortunate to have this multiple
experiences for the job I I had now but
let me highlight three first how
critically important it is to prepare
for a crisis kind of think of the
unthinkable and then act with some
foresight when a shock hits you you have
a title for this series called build
back better I actually would like to
modify it if you if I may and I would I
would talk about built better before
preparedness prevention pay off big time
the second and not necessarily in
priority it is
important is collective action working
together seeking help offering help
makes a huge difference in emergency and
the third is something I learned time
and again we don't know our internal
strength until we are hit
we're sorry zillions we are so able to
withstand shocks especially when we come
together that this always gives me this
sense of optimism that as hard as it is
we can overcome it from the days when my
country collapsed the economy collapsed
I would get up at 4 o'clock in the
morning queue to buy milk for my
daughter to the days when I would see
Syrian refugees in terrible situations
helping each other to today when I'm at
the head of the IMF that internal
strength our power of resilience the
more we are together the more it is
amplified actually could you talk a bit
more about the role of the IMF
especially as we look forward to trying
to recover from this what what
specifically can your organization do to
take us forward so there are three
things that are quite unique for the IMF
and they're really so important in a
time of crisis the first one is to give
a good diagnostic of what is happening
and what is the way forward let me just
say in this crisis in the very first
weeks we put together we call it policy
action tracker for a hundred and ninety
three countries what actions are
countries taking how they can learn from
each other so they we can be more
effective together we are adding to it
now actions for responsible reopening of
the economy
exactly with that purpose what we are
known best for yeah we are the financial
first responder we are coming in this
incredible shock with very significant
financial firepower and what people
don't know is that the fund has multiple
instruments emergency Finance Inc is the
one we doubled for this crisis and it is
no conditionalities we are asking want
increase pay your doctors in your nurses
your hospitals protect your most
vulnerable people and parts of the
economy that's it this is the condition
and the third thing we we do at the
front is to help countries have the
capacity for good policies after the
financial crisis we helped many
countries to have good debt management
good fiscal management transparency and
accountability to improve the
performance of public finance so the
fund is not a very big organization by
any standard we are some 3,000 people
highly professional incredibly committed
when you use the expression all hands on
deck that's us and it is a digital deck
it is a digital business I mean this is
a global crisis a lot of people are
worried that unlike perhaps even in 2008
where it really did seem there was a lot
of global cooperation there's actually
in some worrying ways less this time
are you are you worried about how
crucial is that to getting us through
this I mean my my preoccupation is in
our mandate in my area of responsibility
bring the membership together we have
almost the whole world a country 10 18 9
countries around members and so far I am
very impressed by how responsive the
membership has been I put in front of
them
in the spring a package very strong
package of measures to expand the role
of the IMF in the crisis everything that
we asked for we asked for doubling
emergency financing we got it very
interesting we asked for tripling
concessional financing exactly because
you know like the virus hits people with
weak system the hardest the crisis hits
weak economies the hardest so we wanted
to triple concessional financing within
one month we got it we asked for grants
for debt relief we got it so what I'm
trying to say here is that we need to
focus on ways in which we bring the
world together and then act on that
rather than complaining that maybe not
everything is the way it should be
do your duty to do to the global
community well indeed and the IMF is is
dependent on the financing from its
members its key members the I mean you
spoke of the trillion dollars that you
are looking to make available to nations
that need it as I read it that that
comes from you've got this front this
these these units called Special Drawing
rights that you basically draw a
currency from members and it hasn't had
been pushed back though from the u.s. to
to block that that effort of raising all
that money so the one trillion dollars
is from our quarters and also from our
ability to move money from well-to-do
members from the advanced economies and
lend it at very low or zero interest to
the developing emerging markets and we
had this one trillion in what was very
interesting not everybody not is that
the US in the two trillion dollars
stimulus package include
the support for the IMF the Special
Drawing rights is something that we
indeed don't have yet consensus among
the membership to do it was done during
the 2009 crisis issuing liquidity and it
goes to everybody and there are many
voices including mine I spoke to the g20
about about that that are saying well
that may be a good thing to do now
it is not being supported for four
reasons it is not not just capriciously
the problem with Special Drawing rice is
that when we issue them they go to all
members and the advanced economies get
62% of the new allocation and there are
some that are saying can we think of
something that is more directed or
exclusively directed to those who who
need it but Chris everything is on the
table for us as as the crisis and Falls
we do we need to do more we bring the
membership to do more when we and so we
actually have a question from the
community that sort of builds on what
what you're discussing right now
yep Nika Akana asks which countries will
prove to be resilient in the great
transformation those with popular
leaders or those with sound financial
systems you know they both matter
countries with strong fundamentals are
clearly going through this crisis with
less trauma that does that had weak
fundamentals to begin with and of course
leadership but matters how you mobilize
a country for for action matters in my
view what we would see on the other side
the winners would be those who think
today this crisis also as an opportunity
clearly digital transformation
is a huge opportunity moving car to
eLearning ye government it payments
ecommerce linkings small and
medium-sized enterprises through digital
to consumers big winner
secondly I very much hope that we would
come on the other side with low carbon
footprint and a more climate resilient
economy those who move in this direction
they would reduce the risk for
themselves in the world from this other
crisis that we are not talking so much
about these days but it hasn't gone
anywhere and you know if you don't like
pandemic you're not gonna like the
climate crisis at all and also countries
that are thinking of how to make the
economy in the future a fairer economy
in other words we have been seeing
inequality building up before this
crisis my colleagues who have researched
pandemics have a very bitter lesson for
us after pandemics after h1n1 after SARS
after Zika inequality goes up well are
we going to let inequality to go up up
after this crisis and if we do we are
damaging the fabric of our societies and
myself is that hundreds of millions of
people in this crisis would much prefer
to have simpler fairer more equitable
world to live in and definitely more
sustainable world
don't just
definitely and just one more question
from our community before turning it
back to Christopher for for some final
questions here but you know as you this
one is from Sara Rue Kaymer
and the question is what do you see as
the main potential positive shifts and
changes in this world from this pandemic
say two to ten years from now I touched
upon it a little bit first I hope to see
fiscal policies to help us recover to be
geared towards green recovery and more
equitable recovery and that is something
that is in the hands of policymakers it
can be done
secondly I very much hope to see us
integrating what we have learned from
the crisis in terms of virtual work my
organization the IMF well we can shrink
our carbon footprint dramatically just
by sustaining the practices we are
developing now and we will
I certainly hope to see in the Indo in
the future much more attention to two
things that we saw in this crisis are
essential universal access to health in
some form strong health systems as well
as strong social safety nets built as
automatic stabilizers in a time of shock
and by the way it is cheaper if we do it
in this way the bill for everyone is
going to be smaller and also I very much
hope that this notion of investing in
people recognizing that now that we see
this horrible tragedy the loss of lives
that investing in people is the very
best investment we can make
hmm that's great so see it again in a
minute Whitney okay it's it's so it's
it's so inspiring actually hearing the
energy and stuff the energy that you
bring into this I don't think many
people coming into this would have
expected to hear from the head of the
IMF this emphasis on you know let's
let's solve the crime crisis let's
tackle inequality and injustice
it's um do you really believe that this
moment this crisis could help lead us
into a great transformation I mean
people will feel it's your job to sound
positive you have to do that do you
really see the path forward that we can
get get through this and how what sort
of time scale are we talking about here
Christina well you know one thing I
learned from the transition I lived
through the transition from center
planning to markets is it is tough it is
long it is painful and it is a road that
takes turn so I I don't have an
expectation of miracle from here to
there but I genuinely believe that we
are now in a point of our history when
people demand from their leaders safety
and security and a society that is not
torn apart by conflicts and that is
actually not unusual to see so I would
turn the table a little bit on you Chris
after the after a war we see the world
coming together and and building a
better world why not after a pandemic
and
yes we can make mistakes and not take
the right router to travel but we
certainly have an obligation to try to
get on that road so if you can just
everybody matters every bet so if you
could inject one idea into the mind of
everybody only to the world leaders who
listen to you
what what would that idea be at this
moment optimism built a better world
possible desirable we must do it that
sounds like optimism as the starts not
just a naive belief that it will happen
but a determination to make it so that's
what you're calling for to use that as
the motivation to pull us all forward
together
Chris do I kept one minute or I'm done I
need to go wait if you have if you want
to say one last thing on one minute
all right go I want to say one thing to
recommend to the audience to watch the
movie bridges of spice there is a part
in the movie in which the two main
actors the lawyer and the Russian spy
talk to each other lawyer says things
are very bad it looks like you may hang
the spies very calm lawyer says aren't
you worried the spice answer would it
help
so my messages it is tough but worries
won't help positive action will positive
stay positive so that's my message well
I have to say thank you you know it's
incredibly inspiring actually to see
your energy and your determined
to assume let's let's call it that I
think we wish you the very best as you
use your position to help get us out of
this mess thank you so much Christina
for spending time here at Ted thank you